- She's a singer, songwriter,
actress, and filmmaker.
She's one of the best selling
artists of all-time worldwide
with over 245 million records sold.
She's the only recording artist
to have a number one album
in each of the last six decades.
She's Barbara Streisand,
and here are her top
ten rules for success.
- A man's reach should exceed his grasp.
It's just, life is a carousel,
life is a bowl of cherries,
I don't know it's,
life is short.
And you just got to
play, dance, experiment,
fail, succeed, learn, give.
In life it's like, you
know, follow your bliss.
If you're following a path
that is pleasurable to you,
it's much easier, it flows,
there's a light behind the eyes you know.
There's a shine within.
It's beyond, it's not just
work, it's a joyous experience.
You long for that.
As I got older, I just thought,
how many people said to me,
how could you not sing in
public, like we as your fans
really want to hear you and see you live.
And I thought, I owe this to them.
And maybe I owe it to myself
too to build up the courage
to try it again, because
it's not about perfection,
as you know, you know.
This could happen, your
voice could go flat, dadada,
and there is a certain excitement to that,
and a certain acceptance again
of, you know, imperfections.
My mother had a great voice.
Not like mine, not like my
sister's, not like my son's.
A high soprano voice, but like a bird,
I mean, really beautiful, but,
I used to say mom, why didn't you try to
get a career as a singer?
No, she said she was too
shy, she couldn't do it.
And I'm basically shy too, but
that makes the difference, you know,
how do you succeed if you don't try?
The truth is, I think for years I thought,
well, I don't want to disappoint people.
You know, it's like you
have this thing for me,
well if you meet me, you know,
will you be disappointed,
will it destroy the mystique?
Now as you get older
and when you accept
your own imperfections,
there's a warmth to that,
that's like the Indians sewing
in the flaw in the blanket,
you know, that it shouldn't be perfect.
So I really can't make a mistake,
because if I accept my flaws,
then you will accept my flaws.
- [Hostess] Exactly.
- Music is,
is transporting, music elevates
life, you know, music is
larger than life.
You know, when you have certain emotions,
that are larger than
life, you want to sing,
you want to, you want to
express it in a larger way.
Music is so powerful to the soul.
It's so rich and being able
to identify with feelings.
Music can transport.
So it's very strong.
- Did you have a lot of people
say you were never going to
make it besides your mom?
- Yeah.
- [Rosie] And what did
you think in your head
when they'd say that?
- I thought they were crazy.
- Same thing with me, that's what I did.
- (laughing) It's terrible.
No, I mean, I thought I
knew their, what meant,
I knew why they thought that but,
isn't that funny that
within enormous insecurity and doubt,
was a kind of a
- [Rosie] A knowing.
- A knowing that, you know
if I stick to my guns,
and I tell the truth
and I, I will be there,
I don't know, I never
thought about it that much.
It was something so deep I guess, that -
I tell people, some
people ask me you know,
do you think I should be an actress?
And I say, boy, if you
have to think about it,
don't be it.
- Now I can direct,
people know I can direct,
now I can write songs, people
know I can write songs,
I don't need to do that anymore?
- I do bore myself a lot.
You know I have to go on, and it's not
conquer, I don't know if
I'd use the word conquer,
it's, it's expanding one's horizon.
You know, it's trying something new.
It's risking failure.
Even that's exciting to me.
You see, actually you have to be
thankful for people
like that 'cuz in a way,
they gave you more courage,
they gave you more energy.
More of a sense of your own destiny.
- It's true.
- I thank my mother actually
for not believing in me.
Because I really set out to prove to her,
that she was wrong, that I
could make something of my life,
you know, as an actress.
I am proud say I am.
But there is no such thing as perfection,
and I found that out
when I was 15 years old,
I wrote it in my journal,
that perfection is imperfection.
So it has that humanity, a human quality.
Otherwise it's too cold, right?
You could just strive for perfection.
Better word is excellence,
strive for excellence.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because a.l.
interpretations asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know,
which of Barbara Streisand's top ten rules
most resonated with you,
leave it in the comments,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
continue to believe and I'll see ya soon.